i want to tell you about a contest that
i'm running with a friend of mine james
schloss
who some of you might recognize from the
youtube channel laos os and his twitch
stream and things like that
also now there's a 3b1b podcast but more
on that in just a moment
basically we want there to be more math
explanation
online and we want to encourage more
people to get started actually doing it
we're calling it the summer of math
exposition where essentially we're just
inviting anyone who wants to to submit
some kind of math explainer whether
that's a video or a blog post or an
interactive game or
whatever it is that explains math online
in some way to the link that's on screen
now
by august 22nd and then once we
yes i see you
would you like to sniff at the
microphone oh yes that's very sweet
very sweet you're a very affectionate
creature
all right where was i anyway after
august 22nd we're gonna have a selection
process to choose
some winners from among them and then
i'll feature them in a three blue one
brown video
and then for the rest i'll probably also
put together a playlist of all of the
videos and a list of links on the
website somewhere to all the project
submissions
and then i was also thinking maybe i
would send something to the winners like
creating some custom gold plushy pie
creatures or something like that
but the main prize is to have your work
featured and hopefully get it out to a
few more people
the reason i'm interested in doing this
is i think there's a lot of people out
there who
would be really good at doing this would
have some excellent explanation that
would genuinely help a lot of people
or show a topic that's not really
covered very well elsewhere
and who might even be thinking about
doing it you know there's that back of
your mind spot that says
maybe one day i'll try my hand at a
video or just write this up as a blog
post
but you just never really got around to
it you know life's busy you're not sure
where to start
it seems like there's a lot of other
things out there and my hope is that by
dangling
the tiniest carrot that i can provide
just mentioning good work when it exists
then maybe that gets a couple more
people over this hump who
might otherwise not have made something
and then actually make it
so one of the very few constraints on
entries for this particular contest
is that it has to be something new it
can't be a thing that you made a while
ago and you're just submitting a link to
it now
but something that you make between now
and august 22nd
and the real spirit of this all is to
encourage people
who have never tried it before to get
started in it somehow
the other constraint is that it does
have to be about math but
math in the broadest possible sense of
the term so that could include physics
or computer science
as long as it's got some mathy
components to it so if you're doing
physics
and there's formulas that are relevant
don't shy away from those formulas
or if you're doing some computer science
and there's some you know algorithmic
complexity or something mathematical to
it
try to lean into that a little bit more
other than that the topic matter is
completely up to you so maybe you have
some topics that you've seen
or that you've learned about but which
you really feel aren't covered well
online anywhere and it would really be
adding something new to the space maybe
you're a physics buff who is interested
in the philosophical side of things
and you've learned about conway's
freewheel theorem and you want to talk
about it and whether that's an
appropriate name whether it's actually
philosophically interesting or not
or just share with people what it is or
maybe you're someone who's into
information theory and things like that
and you've learned about how kolmogorov
complexity can be used to describe some
things about the distributions of primes
and you think that's actually an
interesting angle for how to introduce
kolmogorov complexity in the first place
or anything like this where it's
something kind of new to the space if
that's you
you should definitely consider
submitting but it doesn't have to be a
topic that
no one has ever covered or that's
severely undercovered online
even if it's something that's very
standard and especially if it's
something that a lot of students have to
reach at some point
coming up with a better way to explain
it kind of thinking about what's the
state-of-the-art explanation on any
particular thing
that could also add a lot to the space
say for example you've taught students
about partial fraction decomposition and
tutoring or teaching or something like
that
and you feel like you've come across a
way of explaining it that makes it a
little bit more memorable
you should definitely submit or maybe
you have some really pretty way to
visualize certain trig identities that
students run into
that keeps them from feeling very rote
and instead sheds a light on you know
how beautiful math can be and all that
kind of thing
if that's you and you feel passionate
about it you should definitely submit
that
one set of people who i'm particularly
interested in for this competition
are the teachers and the lecturers and
basically anyone with a lot of
boots to the ground experience seeing
people learn and seeing what actually
works
because i think there's a lot of
outstanding explanations out there
that stay largely confined to the
classroom or otherwise stay offline
whereas if just a little bit of effort
was put into producing it or sharing it
online in some way
those lessons might actually reach and
benefit one to two orders of magnitude
more people
and i get it teachers are absurdly busy
they don't have time for extra things on
the side
and it's kind of hard to know where to
get started so maybe one potential
partnership here would be
the teachers who have really good
instincts for what works in education
and then a student who maybe has a lot
of energy or desire to get started on
youtube or
otherwise just has more free time on
their hands and pairing something
together like that
might actually make for a good
partnership in either case whatever
category you fall into
i do know there's a lot of people who do
want to get started with this because
they write to me
a lot and one of the most common
sentiments out there is
well i don't know where to get started
right i want to make a video but i don't
really have any experience with video
making things like that
and i have a couple things to say for
someone who feels like they're in that
boat
in a kind of loose conjunction with this
contest i decided to start
a podcast where for the first many
conversations i'll be interviewing
people who have
some kind of experience in the space of
putting out explanations
so that could be other youtubers but it
could also include mathematicians who
are really engaged with outreach
or the founder of khan academy things
like this and essentially
have conversations which act to either
inspire or otherwise inform
anyone who might be getting started with
this after doing several of these
interviews
one of the most useful pieces of
information that i think comes out from
them
is just how ramshackle and
unprofessional the setup for a lot of
people is in the very beginning
and as a result it should come as no
surprise that one of the most common
pieces of advice one of the most
universal answers to the question of
what advice would you give to someone
getting started with this
is to just start the things that
differentiate the people who actually
put stuff out there
versus the ones who don't is not a
matter of having a lot more experience
with it beforehand
it's a matter of having a kind of
generative spirit that just wants to
make stuff
because my i'll say persona but this is
g you know me this is genuinely me
is give it a go you're probably going to
fail
but it's worth a try i get a lot of
people kind of saying oh you're like you
make youtube videos i've always wanted
to make youtube videos and i'm like
great just do it and they're like no no
but i need to buy a nice camera and i
need to get a good set and i'm like no
no no
like just do it there's always this
temptation wait am i ready yet am i
ready yet and i just say sal
press record and start see what happens
if i take the example which i know best
which is
my own there are so many really
embarrassing things about the early
videos on this channel or my process in
creating them
i mean the sound quality was pretty
terrible for a long time is that's one
big
thing i edited in imovie for
way longer than i care to admit also
despite being now a
like professional youtuber when it comes
to cameras and actually filming things
like this
i really have no idea what i'm doing
like right now i'm just using a phone
which i guess is fine
i find the process of being alone in a
room and just talking
to a camera incredibly awkward
this is actually my second time
recording this whole video
because the first time i thought i would
be really clever and have some notes to
like guide what i wanted to say and i'd
put them
on the monitor next to the camera but
what the result was is that
i would just kind of have my eyes
darting back and forth between
the two without me consciously realizing
it it was just this reminder that i
really don't know what i'm doing
but this isn't a self-effacing thing the
point here is that if you
find yourself with a potentially good
explainer that you want to make
but you're a little self-conscious about
how to start or you're worried that
you're going to make a mistake
just don't worry about it just dive
right in so many of us have
no idea what we're doing when we begin
all that said sometimes this just do it
advice
is a little bit frustrating because i
mean it's not actionable
you say okay i'm going to start but then
upon starting
it tells you nothing so in the spirit of
some more concrete advice i do have a
couple things that i might want to pass
along
that are specific to the case of math
explainers
the first one and i do actually find
this quite important is when you're
putting together the explanation
whatever form whatever medium whatever
genre you choose
try to be aware of the layers of
abstraction that are relevant to your
topic
so like if you're teaching a young child
about fractions and you're talking about
two-thirds plus one-fifth
there's two different layers of
abstraction that that expression lives
in
there's one where you have a very
concrete example of two-thirds of
something two-thirds of a cake
and then one-fifth of a cake and trying
to get a sense of what that means
and then there's the symbols and a big
part of the lesson at play here
is understanding how the symbols relate
to the actual case and why the rules
that we apply to the symbols make sense
in light of the concrete case
and also why we opt to do the more
abstract thing because it takes much
less thinking
than actually trying to reason about you
know two-thirds of a kick plus one-fifth
of a cake
and this happens at all levels if you're
teaching a calculus class and you're
talking about optimizing functions
you know there's the idea of a function
as a very abstract thing that could be
any particular function or any
differentiable function or what have you
and then there's lots of specific
examples or maybe specific cases where
they come up like a function defining
the
profit of a company and that's the thing
you want to optimize
i made a whole video about group theory
where in the middle i went on for a
while about
the difference between thinking of group
actions as these abstract entities
versus as
something concrete like asymmetry and
why there exists the two and what the
benefits and tradeoffs are
but my point in this first piece of
advice is not merely to address the
layers of abtraction
you don't even have to but if you're
clear in your own head
try very hard to structure your
explanation to go from the concrete to
the abstract
i think almost always when you
understand something
the natural inclination is to go the
other way around i find myself doing
this in pretty much any first draft of a
script that i have
it seems like all the textbook authors
that i ever read tend to do this you
start with the abstract idea you put the
examples later
but i really do think that in the case
of learning first
trying to populate the learner's mind
with a bunch of examples of things that
have a similar pattern between them
and letting their brain do the
abstraction see that similar pattern
between things
such that when you bring in that higher
layer you start defining you know an
abstract vector space or you're doing
some symbolic manipulations with
particular rules
that once that happens you're
articulating something in the brain of
the learner
that was already sitting there in the
first place it wasn't just handed to
them in a vacuum
otherwise it's a little bit like trying
to build a building from the top floor
down
so that's one and that's very specific
to math as a more generic idea piece of
advice number two
would be keep in the very forefront of
your mind the fact that
content is king that the thing that
you're explaining the choice of the
topic or how you're explaining it
determines the majority of the value and
the quality of the thing that you make
all the things about production quality
or you know how fancy the animations are
or the lighting or whatever it is
all of that is secondary to making sure
you've chosen an actually good topic
and it's something that people would
want to consume they haven't seen it
elsewhere it's offering something fresh
now that's so easy to nod along with and
say like yes yes of course content is
king
but the thing is you end up spending
about one percent of your time
if that choosing what you're going to
explain and how you're going to explain
it
and then like 99 of the time just
carrying it out in some way
and as a result it can be easy to lose
sight of that important part
so my encouragement to you would be
spend more time than you would otherwise
tend to
on choosing that topic so maybe workshop
a couple different things by doing
sample lessons with people
or try to write out a list of all the
different things that you could and ask
are they actually fresh are they
actually adding something to the space
is there a reason someone would want to
consume this spending that extra little
bit of time
on the thing that determines the
majority of the value is almost
certainly worth it
and the third piece of advice which
maybe plays into this a little bit
is when you're beginning if you're just
starting something fresh and there's no
presence online at this point
try to choose something much more
esoteric and specific than you might be
inclined to
i've seen a lot of people who want to
get started on youtube for example
and the way that they try to go about it
is to choose a topic that will appeal to
the most people
after all they want their video to blow
up they want a lot of subscribers and
things like that
but there's a couple issues with this
first of all it's a much more
competitive space if you're going to try
to describe something
that a lot of people might be searching
for so if you go in saying
i'm going to do a series about quantum
mechanics well there's a billion others
out there and
yours is going to have to stand out for
some reason and you don't have a
foothold at that point
but another one is that the very
specific and niche things
build a much more loyal audience in that
beginning because you're offering
something which they could not find
anywhere else
and sometimes to be the consumer of
something very specific is such a good
feeling
that you want to pay it back and you
find yourself rooting for the creator
so you're much more likely to get very
good faith feedback um just a warmer
community and
also oftentimes we tend to overestimate
just how niche things are
like sometimes something that's so
weirdly specific some very
esoteric bit of engineering actually
appeals to
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people especially if you yourself are
enthusiastic about it and people can
index on that
so by doing that you find yourself often
with a topic that
actually does have a broader appeal but
it's not competitive with the things
that everyone
thinks will have broader appeal and you
potentially get that audience loyalty
when i started this channel i really was
thinking of it as a very niche thing i
did not think it would be a thing that a
lot of people would want to watch
i actually specifically wanted to find
topics in math that no one would think
to search for that was kind of the
original conception that i
wavered from a little bit afterward the
fourth piece of advice is to
pick a genre that your piece falls into
so the other day i was giving this talk
to a group of people and one of them
wanted to get started
making online explainers and they asked
whether it was
ethical for someone who's just barely
learning a topic just starting to learn
it
to also make explainers of it online i
mean after all they're more likely to
make mistakes they don't know the
broader context
and there's so many things i like about
that question it's already demonstrating
a kind of
care and consideration for factual
accuracy and
doing right by the student that more
people who are making online
explanations should consider
so like that very fact suggested to me
that this person probably should be
doing it
but one of the things i suggested is to
acknowledge there are different
types of explainers out there there's
the type where the narrator is a little
bit more distant they're kind of
standing on top of a hill and explaining
the way that things are
and to do that you really have to
research the topic very deeply you
should probably know
ten times as much about the topic as
what you're actually saying in the
content
so that you know that you're teeing
things up for where it actually leads or
you're being cognizant of whatever
nuances there are things like that
but another genre entirely is the
discovery journalism
where the person who is learning the
topic kind of just
admits that fact or is is open about the
fact that they're just starting with it
and taking the viewer along a journey
with them and many times that's actually
a better piece of content it's actually
better for learning the topic
and it comes with this inbuilt piece of
humility that a lot of online content
lacks
but there's lots of other genres like
this there's the worked example where
you're explicitly helping people with
homework
there's the try to find an interesting
demo and serve mainly to inspire
and basically just before you get
started decide which one of those you
feel like you're the best fit for
and then when you're looking at other
pieces out there other explainers
and trying to index off of you know what
seems to work what doesn't
be aware of which ones are in the lane
that you intend to be in and don't
necessarily pattern match off of the
ones that aren't
you know one of the mistakes i think i
made with my very first video is
i had this conception that sometimes if
you talk faster than is comfortable on
the internet
that sort of works that's like a
satisfying thing to consume
because there are videos out there that
are this fire hose of information
and something about that scratches a
niche and i think people like it but
what i didn't really appreciate was the
fact that
math should fall into a completely
different category than that it is not
fun at all to have math come at you at
this fire hose rate
and basically i was just pattern
matching off of things that i should not
have been pattern matching off of
as point number five or i don't actually
know where i am at the list at this
point
especially in the case of math if you're
bringing up definitions of things
try not to let them feel too arbitrary
try to let them be
well motivated explain why that's the
definition what else it could have been
try to make it something that the
learner feels like they discovered
themselves
because too often we hand these things
down on high as the starting point
and it's not really clear why or where
that came from
so all of that is just on the content
side you know what exactly are you
explaining
independent of the multimedia component
of it you know the sound and the video
and all that
and like i said content is king that
definitely determines the majority of
quality
but it does actually matter a little bit
beyond that to have
at least a little bit of production
quality i think and i'll give a really
good example so i was watching this
lecture the other day
by tadashi tokida on just a really
interesting set of ideas about
applying physical intuition to solving
math problems and he had in their maybe
seven or eight outstanding little
arguments that each one of which could
have been just a beautiful video in its
own right
but the you know the talk was over zoom
and the intro was really long and the
sound quality is everything that you
assume from zoom
and the lighting of his shot was weird
and the talk was really good and i do
think you know
it's great that it's online and a lot of
people will be consuming it
but it's probably fair to say that if
all of that content the actual set of
ideas
was instead say a number file video it
would reach 100
times as many people and more than that
it would be a more pleasant experience
for those who are consuming it
and it really doesn't take that much so
i'll just end with a couple pieces of
advice on that front
the first one which again i acknowledge
is very hypocritical here
is sound quality actually matters
especially in an era of zoom where we
are all
inundated with this sort of sub-optimal
version of the voices of all the people
in our lives
the learner will appreciate a respite
from all that with something that
actually comes from a good microphone
that you learned how to use at some
point
[Music]
on the side of visuals you know i'm
obviously a big believer in the idea
that
a well-chosen illustration or an
animation can really make a mathematical
idea a lot more clear and be an example
of that concretization and kind of going
from the lower layer of abstraction
on upward by just showing exactly what
it is on screen in some way
now the way i do things is with
programmatic animations i sort of wrote
this custom library called manum to do
that
and last year actually a group of people
that called themselves the manum
community
created a fork of it with the hope of
making a lot more user-friendly
and i think they succeeded with that
there's a lot better documentation it's
better
tested just all around friendlier to use
so you can use that tool and
thanks to them it's actually a lot
easier than it used to be there's some
other libraries that i've seen that
mention manum as an inspiration
you know one that's written in julia or
one that's in haskell and it doesn't
have to be programmatic either
i think where programmatic animations
make sense for math
is if you're somehow leveraging loops or
conditionals
or layers of abstraction and in the
right context i think it can be a
wonderful way to let the
visuals authentically reflect the math
that you're describing if the
code is essentially just that math as
it's illustrating things
but it doesn't have to be and a lot of
times people use manum or other
programmatic animations for things
that do not need to be programmatic that
you could have easily done in something
like keynote
or which add flashiness for flashiness's
sake that doesn't actually aid with the
explanation
um i think one really good example of
using traditional animation software
is the channel borrbach so he really has
these
friendly handwritten kind of whiteboard
lectures
but uses animation to help those
whiteboards come alive
and he uses adobe animate for that and i
think it's a really nice way to make
this
friendly hand-drawn environment come to
life which is
different from kind of the platonic
stark this is precisely what the math
would draw when you're you know
illustrating a surface or something like
that
also i see a lot of people use manum to
manipulate algebraic expressions and
things like that
but if you look at other videos things
like mathologer you know he's doing a
lot of that in powerpoint
and again content is king the first
thing is to focus on what are you
actually describing
and then just showing it however is
easiest to show it in that case
works totally fine you don't need
anything extremely precise or that
leverages loops and abstraction for the
formulas
i recognize the kind of hypocrisy here
but you know i have walked myself into a
certain corner with the style that i
want for the channel
if you do want to go down that hole of
programmatic animations though another
tool which has popped up
recently is something called
smoothstep.io
which i think is a really nice way for
people to get started with shaders which
are
an absurdly powerful way to do absurdly
beautiful things
and it's written by this guy matt
henderson who has a twitter account that
everyone should follow because he has
some of the most beautiful math
illustrations that i think i've ever
seen
so experimenting with software like that
is another rabbit hole that you could go
down
if say you want to use this competition
as an excuse to try something new
something that you've always wanted to
get started with but
never really had the excuse to do now if
you have some pieces of advice that you
want to pass along to people
or if you want to just engage with the
community in some way to see what other
people are thinking of making or propose
your own project ideas get feedback
talk about software anything like that
we did set up a discord space
associated with the summer of math
exposition there's a link in the
description
uh just be mindful if you do contribute
to that community that you want your
comments to be
encouraging to others who are getting
started and productive to that goal
and you know try to avoid anything that
is the opposite of that goal
and again another source of what will
hopefully include some
inspirational or informative things will
be the podcast
the first episode is out now it's with
the mathematician alex contorevich who
some of you may recognize from the video
he did with qanta or
the video he did with veritasium on pi
day the episode after that is going to
be with sal khan
and there's just a really interesting
lineup of people here so i think you'll
enjoy it
you can get it wherever you get your
podcasts there's a video version of it
which
is going to live on a second channel
that is just my name grant sanderson
and i figure for all future videos that
are a little bit like this one that's
not really animated math but other stuff
that's probably the channel that i'll
put it on so keep an eye on that channel
if that's something that you're
interested in
and i will say this about the podcast
even though the original intent was
something that was
very much tied to this competition and
the idea of targeting people interested
in getting started
a lot of the times i would find myself
with an interesting guest and i just
have a whole bunch of other things that
i want to ask them that have nothing to
do with that
so maybe the better framing here is to
say that the podcast is
20 about that goal and the other 80
is just the usual interview style
podcast vibe where
you have interesting guests and i just
want to ask things that i'm genuinely
curious to know about them
and then i get to grad school and i'm
moving into my my office in grad school
and i have my
all my old papers and i just started you
know for fun leafing through them i
don't know if you ever
look back at the stuff you wrote
freshman year
and i look at him like what the hell was
i writing oh my god this is
garbage this is complete the epsilons
and deltas are backwards you can't have
the epsilon
deltas be backwards and he only took off
three points that would have taken off
you know nine or something like
romney was so nice so if lean was around
back then boy would it have straightened
me out it's actually very inspiring to
me because i feel
one of the common pieces of advice that
i'll give to someone if they like want
to learn more math
[Music]
you